jetzt schauen wir auf die aktuelle lage
in der ukraine denn in der hafenstadt
mario pohl hat eine internationale
evakuierungsaktion zur rettung von
zivilisten aus dem von russischen
truppen belagerten stahlwerk begonnen ja
in konvois mit mehreren bussen wurden
nach ersten angaben bereits mehrere
dutzend zivilisten aus dem asv stahlberg
gebracht die hoffnung die rot jetzt
darauf dass dies der beginn einer
größeren aktion sein könnte
seit wochen harren rund 2000 soldaten
und 1000 zivilisten im stahlwerk der
ukrainischen hafenstadt mario pohl
aussuchen schutz vor russischen beschuss
in den unterirdischen tunneln jetzt
konnten endlich rund 100 menschen
evakuiert werden nachdem bereits am
samstag nach langen verhandlungen 20
frauen und kinder gerettet werden
konnten es ist ein kleiner
hoffnungsschimmer mitten im krieg
ukrainische präsident wurde mir selensky
teilte die hoffnungsvolle nachricht der
evakuierung am sonntag auf twitter heute
ist es uns endlich gelungen mit der
evakuierung aus dem hof stahlwerk zu
beginn nach vielen wochen der
verhandlung nach vielen versuchen
diversen treffen menschen aufrufen
ländern vorschlägen endlich es gab
keinen tag an dem wir nicht versuchen
eine lösung zu finden die unser volk
retten würde heute zum ersten mal in all
den kriegstagen hat dieser
lebenswichtige korridor seine arbeit
aufgenommen erstmals gab es in diesem
gebiet zwei tage waffenstillstand wir
haben es geschafft mehr als 100
zivilisten zu evakuieren vor allem
frauen und kinder
ich hoffe dass morgen alle notwendigen
bedingungen erfüllt sind um die
evakuierung von menschen fortzusetzen
mein dank gilt allen die an der
vorbereitung der menschenrettung
beteiligt waren und diesen humanitären
korridor sicherstellen ich bin allen
dankbar die verhandlungen geführt haben
sie entkamen der hölle von mario polen
und der 45 jahre alter fluchtwagen
rettete die ganze familie der ski gully
pro jahr 1977 hat 500.000 kilometer auf
dem tacho doch die letzten 600 waren die
wichtigsten
in diesem fluchtwagen rettete der
74-jährige potro seine frau tatiana und
seine beiden töchter lena und natalia
aus dem zerstörten mario pohl
unser haus ist am 9 april verbrannt zwei
granaten haben das haus getroffen und es
ist vollständig verbrannt mein auto
wurde zerstört der kofferraum wurde von
kugeln durchlöchert in der stadt gab es
kein wasser die geschäfte hatten
geschlossen es gab überhaupt keine
lebensmittel zu kaufen wir mussten
fliehen
lange hoffte piotr auf einen grünen
korridor um das von russland
kontrollierte gebiet verlassen zu können
doch irgendwann hielt seine familie es
nicht mehr aus wir sind wie durch ein
wunder entkommen unser papa ist ein held
wir uns raus gebracht hat das auto ist
kaputt baujahr 75 unser kleiner jolie
und zerschossen es gab keine heckscheibe
wir haben das mit plastikfolie überklebt
das sagt lena die genau wie ihre
schwester als krankenschwester in mario
pohl gearbeitet hat vor zehn tagen
entschlossen sie sich zur flucht doch
gleich am ersten checkpoint drohte alles
zu scheitern auf meinem handy war ein
foto unseres abgebrannten hauses dazu
hatte ich geschrieben die russische welt
ist da die russen waren die frauen in
einem trakt mit ukrainischen
kriegsgefangenen und brachten sie in ein
gefängnis meine schwester und ich wurden
auf dem sofa gesetzt in einer zelle
neben uns waren alkoholiker und solche
leute in einer anderen zelle waren 13
unserer soldaten die auf vier
quadratmeter gestopft wurden darunter
war sogar ein mann der überhaupt kein
aktiver soldat war aber auch er wurde da
reingesteckt die soldaten haben um
wasser gebeten aber nichts kommen die
familie hat alles verloren jetzt wollen
sie nach deutschland kam um erst einmal
in sicherheit leben und den horror
wenigstens im ansatz verarbeiten zu
können doch vielen ukrainern ist die
flucht noch nicht gelungen fakt ist die
situation im stahlwerk ist seit wochen
schlecht es gibt kaum nahrung kaum
wasser und die medikamente für die
vielen verletzten gehen aus so
beschreibt es auch sluma ein
befehlshaber des regiments der als
kämpfer seit wochen im stahlwerk
ausharrt der trinkwasser vorrat ist zu
90 prozent erschöpft wir essen nur
einmal am tag hauptsächlich verschiedene
brei und konserven von denen nur noch
wenige übrig sind es ist sehr feucht in
den bunkern die hälfte der menschen
hustet die ganze zeit aber wir sind
abgehärtete menschen niemand beklagt
sich wir hoffen dass ein drittstaat uns
rausholt sonst bleiben wir für immer
hier kreml diktator wladimir putin hatte
das stahlwerk vergangene woche von
russischen truppen so engmaschig
umstellen lassen dass nicht einmal eine
fliege raus kommt er will die menschen
dort aushungern
eine unfassbar dramatische situation in
diesem maß auf stahlwerk nun haben aber
also erste busse offenbar mit zivilisten
mario pohl verlassen können philipp
jakob ist für uns in sapporo dort sollen
die evakuierten heute ankommen philipp
haben erste busses aprica schon erreicht
was kannst du uns dazu sagen nein die
erste größe haben wir noch nicht
erreicht ich stehe hier auf diesem
marktplatz wo die busse der beiden
nationen ankommen sollen mit etwa 100
menschen die aus dem stallberg wurden
könnte kamen bereits nicht mehr an aus
den gebieten die von russland besetzt
sind aber auch den un convoy wird noch
gewartet und zwar schon seit gestern er
soll aus mario pohl einen ganz weiten
weg zurücklegen und dann über das kleine
nord nach südkorea fahren wir sind
gestern noch einmal diese diese strecke
abgefahren von sevilla nach rechts und
wir können sagen da wird ziemlich heftig
beschossen wir waren circa anderthalb
stunden da es gab über ein dutzend
artillerie einschläge also die russen
bereiten den flüchtlingen wirklich ein
sehr zynischen empfand vor
wie ist es jetzt zu dieser evakuierung
überhaupt gekommen und könnte das
wirklich der anfang einer größeren
aktion werden
der druck auf russland wurde sehr hoch
weil die welt das einfach nicht mehr
ertragen hat diese bilder zu sehen aus
dem stahlwerk mit hunderten braun
kindern älteren menschen die fast kein
wasser mehr haben die fast keine nahrung
mehr haben und die über wochen hinweg in
diesem unterirdischen bunker ausharren
und tagtäglich und russischen
artilleriegeschossen von panzern von der
luftwaffe beschossen werden es sind aber
immer noch viele viele menschen da man
hat sich auch mal nicht darauf einigen
können noch mehr menschen zu retten
hoffentlich klappt das aber man muss
sagen gut ich hatte ganz lange überhaupt
kein interesse daran zivilisten raus zu
lassen weil je mehr zivilisten in diesem
bunker sind desto mehr ablegung
konsumieren sie auch und desto schwerer
haben es die soldaten das ist genau sein
ziel die soldaten sprechen aushungern
bis sie kapitulieren oder sterben
wenn die die evakuierten dann ankommen
im labor etr wie geht es dann für sie
weiter
das hängt sehr davon ab in welchem
zustand die evakuierten flüchtlinge sind
diejenigen die mehr oder weniger gesund
hier ankommen die werden registrierte
bekommen ein bisschen geld sondern
kümmert man sich darum wie es weitergeht
werden dokumente deine unterricht tier
in der nähe oder können weiterfahren zu
verwandten die sie haben so anders no
keine oder auch in anderen ländern dann
gibt es natürlich auch die verwundeten
die werden hier direkt in die
krankenhäuser gebracht denn so sagen
auch die medizinische versorgung im
stahlwerk war natürlich furchtbar da ist
auch schon relativ leichte verwundungen
und wirklich zu sehr schweren
erkrankungen führen und um diese
menschen muss man sich natürlich jetzt
sehr intensiv kümmern
dankeschön für deine ganz aktuellen
eindrücke